two circular sewers each with a slope of
0.5% are undergoing die tests one sewer
is constructed out of brick with cement
mortar and the other sewer is plastic
what can be expected at the conclusion
of this test assume that during the
duration of the die test both sewers are
flowing at a depth of 6
in so the options are the dye in the
brick sewer will appear before the dye
in the plastic sewer sewer the Dy in the
plastic sewer will appear before the Dy
in the brick sewer the Dy in both sewers
will appear at the same time or there is
not enough information to determine
which dye will appear
first so this problem is a really good
example of a problem that can be solved
quickly using conceptual knowledge or
really slowly using brute
math uh this problem gives us enough
information to realize that we can use
Manning's equation to solve for the
Velocity in each
sewer however given that the sewers are
identical except for their material we
can also use our understanding of
hydraulic Concepts to recognize that the
sewer with the higher Manning value aka
the rougher sewer material will be the
sewer with the slower velocity
conversely the sewer with the lower
Manning and value aka the smoother sewer
will have the faster velocity a quick
glance at the table of roughness values
on page
346 shows us that brick and mortar
sewers have a Manning's n of
0.015 while plastic sewers have a
Manning n of
0.013 with this in mind we can see that
the die test in the plastic sewer will
move faster than the dye in the brick
sewer
leading us to our
answer the alternative would have been
to have solved for the hydraulic radius
of a 1T diameter sewer and then used
that to find the velocities of both
sewers for certain problems
understanding theory is all you need and
in this case that's all it took to get
us our answer
[Music]